Here's our third problem with motion. This time we have a speed boat that takes
6 hours to travel downstream when the current is 12 miles per hour. The return
trip for the boat would be upstream and the boat's going to travel at its same
speed. But against the current and that's going to take it 8 hours. Your
challenge is to find the speed of the boat in still water. As always, we'll use
a table to help us get started. So again here, we're looking for the speed of
the boat. So we'll let that be x. See if you can fill in the missing
information for our table. And this time there is something different with our
time column. We're actually given the times to go upstream and downstream. This
means that we'll have numbers here and expressions for distance here. See if
you can figure this one out.